them for the girls
if a guy had everything he wanted would
you overlook cheating
no because that wouldn't be part of what
I wanted yeah
everything okay
Interruption
the catalog yes the cup alarm right
there
[Music]
um what do you mean
um because like if he had everything I
wanted then he would be loyal I guess
and he wouldn't oh yeah but outside of
that so so okay okay let's let me let me
do you how tall you want a guy to be
um I like same height or taller okay so
how tall are you five nine five eight
let's give him what word you seem like a
six three kind of girl
six four six three sixes
okay I do um taller but I can settle for
the same height
yeah okay so let's say six three he's
got money status could you overlook
cheating you don't think you could uh
and you don't have to work again
yeah I don't know you know I think I
probably could just because I I don't
know okay and you said no it's like
everything I wanted and Advance like my
career and all of that then sure okay
what about you no it's not something I
would accept to be honest would you
prefer a guy you liked less and that was
faithful yeah 100 okay you too yeah I
think you know what I wish I was and
this is not because there's anything
wrong in forgiving and moving on I wish
I was more forgiving but I think
um I'm not strong enough and I'm not
forgiving enough as a person and it
makes me too insecure if I was more
secure in myself and I was more able to
let go it'd be fine but because I'm
already not the most secure person there
is adding that to it I just won't be a
good partner going forward I won't be
the best version of me I'll you'll get a
different version of me and one that is
not worth staying with so I wouldn't be
able to for his for the sake of us I I
don't think it would work I think yeah
um I hate what you guys are saying yeah
um I believe that I think it kind of
just depends on how how you discover
that it's cheating if you know that when
he says he's going I don't know to
Manchester or to Liverpool or something
like that then that's what he's doing
um but you don't have like actual
evidence I don't feel like he would go
looking for the evidence if he's got
your whole situation set up yeah if you
get embarrassed and someone's coming up
to you like yo then I feel like maybe
it's different it's a bit different but
I feel I think a lot of women would play
a blind eye to it as long as they don't
feel publicly disrespected I think the
thing is they
you know what um the thing is
women share men all the time if you're
dating someone casually for example or
if you're in a situationship you're
usually sharing them and you kind of
already know I think it's just like what
you said about it don't just want it
rubbed in their faces but you'd be
surprised really surprised on what some
women will put up with if they're with
someone they actually like do you
sometimes they prefer you know the
situation rather than uh they do know
you've got a mean person yeah yeah do
you think they are more comfortable I
think women would be more comfortable
with that because there's no suspicion
involved it's actually like that's what
you're doing he's cheating on you and he
wants you to be faithful though that's
the thing it's not like a free fall
it's just like okay I'm doing my thing
but hey you got you got a pattern as
well it depends at the stage as well and
answer your question so
um you can tell them from the get-go
this is the situation yeah and then they
have the choice if they want to get on
board yeah or sometimes it doesn't come
out until later and then they have to
find out and I've I can't speak for
anyone else but I've had I've had
someone say to me I don't care I just
don't want to see it
in general like modern women like are
side chicks for sure yeah 100 I mean if
you look at dating app data it's you
can't deny it we swipe right five
percent of the time on the same guys
basically and then on top of that like
what what comes first typically
typically and I know I know there's
exceptions but sex are relationships so
yeah so he's right you start off as a
side chick do you think Modern Men are
side men without realizing because men
go for the top women as well either I
don't think no no no that's not
statistically true they swipe right 45
of the time and it's higher on who do
they like who do they actually want to
be with men really aren't that picky to
be fair like honestly like I mean you
you guys can correct me if I'm wrong if
you're hot enough nice enough young
enough they're they're cool what if
you're not hot if you're out what is it
they just want to take care of it I mean
let's just do that the majority of women
are not
those I know it looks like I disagree no
I think it looks like it because
I think the majority of women we see
publicly on TV on Instagram these are
the women the beautiful women put
themselves out there but the majority of
women when you're walking into Tesco are
not stunners you don't walk into Tesco's
and be like oh my God
actually it's usually
but it's usually based on their own poor
choices though if even in the U.S here
and everyone will call America fat but I
looked at the data here it's not much
better yeah but you're in the top 20 of
women if you're in shape yeah so all you
have to do is be in shape most guys are
fine but I do think it's not um just
women that go for high quality the way
men flock to beautiful women and high
quality women is no different to how
women flock to high quality men if you
take a girl who's not attractive and is
not in shape she doesn't have that same
success online dating she doesn't have
that same success with men she doesn't
have many ideas
I'm telling you you're wrong like that's
statistically
it's statistically wrong an average
chick has more options than a top man if
you look at dating if you an average
girl so average chick gets more matches
than the top men but matches is sex
we're talking about investment women
don't care about sex you've got to
remember that you're measuring men and
women on the same standard who gets the
same level of sex yeah okay of course
sex Divine but women value investment
men value sex so if you look at the
investment an unattractive woman gets
like how many dates does she get taken
on does she get taken seriously do they
introduce her to friends and family that
is comparable to you know that's a form
of investment right right yeah
but what do we say relationships start
with in 2022 six yeah so so that that's
a precursor measuring success in dating
by sex
because if that's what we're measuring
I'm fine
delusional to think that like the top
men have all the leverage they do it's
not comparable the top women do not have
as much leverage as the top man I think
and if they do and if they do give it
five years I'm sorry like 12 like you
hit 30 it's not the same yeah but I do
think top women get the same reaction as
top men and they have the same and I
think more because you know what it is a
Top Value man well most Top Value men
that I know of have very silent
Instagrams they are busy they are CEOs
you don't see them posting up and this
whereas beautiful women they're in your
face all day every day so their DMS are
insane insane so on a day-to-day basis
without any effort that woman can have
five six seven men paying her not just
going on dates with a cash up this that
and the other I don't think a Top Value
man has it as easy as a Top Value women
and men flock the top I just think I
think the difference is the Top Value
man is satisfied with like like
um like the top like they say that eight
nines and tens are for the streets
forever like I've just heard this phrase
in red pill because like if a girl's an
eight she needs a nine or a ten if a
guy's an eight he's okay with a six I
Know I Know Rich guys
most men will cheat most men have give
if given beautiful models every day
they're gonna say yes one day so an
eight will be happy with the six where
the eight that's a girl needs a nine or
a ten so it's a smaller pool that she's
going to be satisfied with I think guys
are just a bit more realistic like long
term with like they just content with
how things are do you pursue a pretty
girl the same way you'd pursue an
average girl would you invest the same
do they get the same Nathaniel out of
you a pretty girl and an average girl
yeah
um
I'll probably are we talking about I'm
sexually attracted to both
no your one is average you can take it
let's make one a six one and eight one's
a six you can't use seven yeah
all right um one's a six one's a eight
the six I don't really see me checking
for the six I'll be honest thank you
um the eight but there's I'll say this
here because there's makeup yeah I feel
like money is the man's makeup because
there's makeup a lot of women can look
like I could think about three different
kind of women that all women can look
like if they if they had the right
makeup
at the end of the day if we're talking
about like you know uh in the morning I
have Peak she's six that's
yeah listen I've seen I've seen some
serious Transformations so if at your
best you're six then
it's mad yeah because I feel like
there's a lot of talk about high value
men but do you know what it's like with
the UK 18 19 year old like pretty girls
getting flown out in private jets and so
look how men treat high value or
beautiful women they drop all the rules
for beautiful women and the same applies
for high value men but they drop every
rule for a beautiful girl are you
arguing that beautiful women have the
same leverage that high value men have
is that is if not more
completely wrong because because what
percent of women are beautiful like I'm
saying no there's there's a new girl
turning 22 every day how about you men
are rare and women women they age out at
like 28 it was rare but now we've got an
Instagram which means a a rich guy in
Nigeria can send you Millions a rich guy
in Qatar can send you a million we have
polarized it so that high value men uh
who aren't bait or aren't big on social
media are limited to the women around
them whereas beautiful women are exposed
to the world but yeah right right so
they might get sex from him but she's
not the main chick
when we established that you can be side
chick even if you're average you can be
a side chick
you're right you're sharing even that's
yours
but that man still has the leverage
because he gets to pick who is who gets
commitment that's why he has the
leverage high leverages in the fact that
she doesn't want commitment from him she
wants lifestyle from you right now so
her leverages I think we're talking
about two different things so I'm
talking about women that want a ring and
Men
and men that want sex okay okay so okay
if we're measuring it by investment and
six then can pretty girls get money yeah
yeah like can they get lifestyle yeah
it's about the maintenance how long can
they keep that up they have these rules
that they don't want to get cheated on
and you know they want to be they want
to keep this up and and there's no one
else anyone that's high value men how
long do you reckon uh women have that
that um leverage for if she's pregnant
forever if she's not pregnant for
foreign
no they want to work but they want a man
that can make a life that if she didn't
work it'd be all right yeah basically
yeah
they weren't the best of everything yeah
if you tell them that I don't want you
to work you're you're controlling them
or you're oppressing them or all you're
the patriarchy but if you say look if
you can if you want to work it's cool if
you want to work that's cool as well
we're good for money okay it's a
different conversation yeah we don't
want to have to work so speaking as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible